middle of the week wednesday have you
made your weekend plans that's why we've
got nate on the town how about a nice
run for you and your furry friend that's
a little bit of a road trip a little
let's see this year's little big dog
trail run it's up in caliente in lincoln
county on saturday it's a 14 k that
starts at 9 a.m 4 k at 9 30. the prices
vary depending on which race you're
doing with your pup or without your pup
more details on their website there you
see it on our screen meanwhile the mount
charleston library hosting snow days
this will be saturday at noon arts and
crafts prizes even whoa a button maker
try to calm yourself
it is free but you want to dress warmly
obviously it's colder up there and how
about some classical music the las vegas
sinfonietta performing all of mozart's
last three symphonies that's going to be
at the this sunday afternoon at three
clark county library flamingo near
maryland parkway it's 28 bucks 14
dollars for students with a valid id
children 12 and under are free